hello everyone i am pranatarkash from
dartmouth college and i am going to talk
about adversarially robust coloring in
graph streams
this is a joint work with my advisor
ramit chakravarthi and manual stalker
now let me begin by describing the
general data streaming model here the
input is a stream of elements let's say
q1 through qm and we have a memory
restricted server which doesn't have
enough space to store the entire stream
so instead it
receives the elements one by one and
maintains a summary of the data
so as it
receives the tokens it after continually
uploads updates the summary
and
its goal is to maintain it in such a way
that
whenever it is queried after some
element qi it gives an output oi from
the set of all valid outputs at that
point
now consider for example the problem of
approximately counting the number of
distinct items
so
when the algorithm is going after qi the
set of all valid outputs are the of all
real values in the one plus minus
epsilon factor of the number of distinct
items at that point
now this model can be seen as a game
played between an adversary and an
algorithm where the adversary designs
the stream and sends it to the algorithm
and queries it while the algorithms
objective is to answer the queries
correctly i'll make this more precise
soon now an adversary can be of two
types oblivious and adaptive
and i'll in the next two slides i'll
explain what i mean by each
so let's consider the oblivious
adversary setting first which is also
called the standard streaming setting
so now the
adversary
fixes a stream in advance and then it
sends the elements one by one to the
algorithm
now whenever the algorithm is queried
after some element q y it should output
an element oi from the set of all valid
outputs at that point
now note that because the adversary has
fixed the stream in advance it cannot
look at the outputs and decides the and
decide the upcoming tokens
so
it cannot figure out what the random
choices the algorithm has made while uh
deciding the stream and so it is
oblivious to the random bits of the
algorithm this is why we call it an
oblivious adversity
in this game the goal of the algorithm
is of course to
already apply with the correct answer
whenever it square it and the
adversary's goal is to make to make it
output an incorrect answer at some point
in the stream
now consider the case of that adaptive
adversary which is also called the
robust streaming on adversarially robust
streaming setting and this particular
version uh this particular
formulation of the setting in terms of a
game was defined by benalizer and others
which
got the best forever in parts 2020.
so here the adversary sends the token q1
to
the algorithm who replies with the
output over and upon seeing this output
one adversary then sends the next stream
token q2 algorithm replace with o2
seeing which the
adversary decides the next element q3
and so on and so forth
now note that the adversary adaptively
decides the upcoming tokens based on the
outputs given by the algorithm
and so when it sends an element qi it is
it is decided by some function of the
previous elements and the
outputs received
so
uh
in the in this case
the adversary can learn about the random
bits used by the algorithm from the
outputs uh given
and then it can continue that stream in
such a way that the final stream turns
out to be one that is bad for the random
bits of the algorithm and thus it can
make the algorithm fail
now if an algorithm
replies with correct answer at all
points even against an adaptive
adversary then we call it adversarially
robust
for example
note that deterministic algorithms are
always robust because they are correct
for any stream
now uh two practical scenarios where uh
this setting comes up is let's say an
user is interacting uh
actively with the database and querying
buffer upon seeing the approaching the
answers it receives or
online streaming or marketing services
like netflix or amazon recommending
items to users based on their history
now consider the problem of streaming
graph coloring where the input arrays
are the stream of edge insertions and
our task is to assign colors to the
nodes of the vertices such that no two
adjacent nodes get the same color
now we want to optimize the number of
colors used
uh now uh
here we focus on coloring with
some function of delta
colors
where delta is the maximum degree of the
graph because coloring with the minimum
possible number as a chromatic number of
colors is a extremely hard problem
now it is known that every graph is
delta plus one color double and this
this coloring is achieved easily because
we can just go over the nodes one by one
and assign
them a color gradiently actually by
assigning the color which is not already
taken up by any of its neighbors
however this algorithm uses linear space
and so this is a
challenging problem even in the
streaming setting
now for the oblivious adversary setting
in uh breakthrough work by assad and
khanna gives a delta plus one coloring
algorithm in semi streaming space that
is in n for a log n space where n is the
number of nodes in the graph i'll use
this notation throughout the paper
however this algorithm is inherently
randomized as uh and so are
other existing algorithms
for graph coloring i think
a couple of which are given by myself
and co-authors suman and amit and a
class of algorithms given by alan and
asadi
and all of these algorithms can be shown
to fail uh against an adaptive adversary
because
he can
figure out
the random bits used by the algorithm
now a natural question is then uh can we
design adversarially robust delta plus
uh an adversarial robust delta plus one
coloring algorithm and this is a
slightly easier question than an open
question raised by asadi in a talk at
simon says institute in 2018 where he
asked can we design deterministic delta
plus one coloring streaming algorithms
this brings me to our results we show
a lower bound that any robust coloring
algorithm that uses k colors
must also use omega n delta squared over
k space
and since all deterministic algorithms
are robust the lower bound also holds
for such algorithms
now two immediate corollaries are that
leave alone delta plus one even an order
delta coloring algorithm
which is robust needs linear space that
is omega n delta space
and then
and robust same streaming coloring
algorithm
it requires omega delta squared colors
now contrast this with the
aforementioned result of azalean khana
which
in the oblivious adversary setting got a
same streaming algorithm with delta plus
one colors
so it shows up uh first separation
between standard and robust streaming
algorithms for a natural problem
and also establishes the first
separation between randomized and
deterministic streaming coloring
algorithms
the first one answers an open question
raised by yuri stemmer at uh stock 21
workshop on robust streaming
and the second one answers the
aforementioned coupon question by asadi
i should mention here that a parallel
work by assadi chen and sun that
appeared on archives uh few days after
our paper uh shows a stronger separation
for deterministic algorithms and they
show that any deterministic
semi-streaming uh coloring algorithm
must use exponential in delta power some
constant colors
now we complement our lower bounds with
some algorithms and we give
an order delta cube robust coloring
algorithm in semi streaming space
now the the version of the algorithm in
the paper uses quite a few that is or
ordered in delta random bits
and i'll talk about it but
we later show that this assumption can
be removed
and
we also give a order delta squared
coloring algorithm in n square root
delta space you know for insert only
streams and for translate streams the
space usage is
ordered square root of n times m
now we generalize these results to get
delta power k coloring in n for n delta
power 1 over k space for instance only
streams for any natural number k
and for turn side streams the space
usage is n power one minus one over k
times m power one over k
now know observe that this establishes a
double separation for uh adversarial
style good numbers in same streaming
space because as noted earlier it
establishes separation from
uh ordinary randomized algorithms uh
well that is the result of a sergeant
khanna and it also
shows that uh
while look for robust coloring
algorithms poly delta color surprises
the result by
uh asa richard and sun says the
deterministic algorithms we need
exponentially in delta colors
now let me describe the significance of
our result in the context of adversarial
robot streaming
so
prior workout and adversarial robustness
for example the work by heart and root
rough in stock 13 and the one by ben as
eliza and others in parts 20 show that
many existing standard streaming
algorithms are not adversely robust
so
when venezuela and and others in this
slide
give a general framework for converting
a standard streaming algorithm to a
robust one
so for
one plus minus epsilon estimating any
function if
given
an algorithm a we that uses space order
is
we can convert it into a rover streaming
algorithm a prime that uses as space s
times lambda where lambda is the flip
number or the number of times the value
of the function f can change by a factor
of 1 plus minus epsilon over a stream of
length m
now it's easy to see that if the stream
is insert only and monotonic then the
lambda value of lambda can be at most
logarithmic and so we can do this
robustification incurring just a log
factor in space
the subsequent word by hasidim and
others uh improve this overhead from
lambda to square root lambda
and other words like the work of
woodruff and zou and
the one by rts and others show that
assuming these something called
difference estimators further
improvements can be done
now uh for turn style streams or
non-monotonic function this flip number
lambda can be very large that is it can
be linear in the stream length and in
this case the
previously mentioned framework
no longer gives an efficient robust
algorithm
and thus
here it's natural to suspect that maybe
the some translated streaming problems
and
problems on non-monitoring functions are
inherently harder
against an adaptive adversary and maybe
there is no such
efficient
robust algorithm so natural question is
to ask for the
okay if we can exhibit a problem that is
significantly harder against an adaptive
adversary than an oblivious one
so
in the in this context uh heart and wood
graph show that this is true for if the
algorithm is a linear sketch uh for that
is for
problems like l2 norm estimation linear
sketches are significantly harder for
against adaptive adversaries than for
oblivious ones
but this doesn't quite rule out that
there can be
efficient robust non-linear algorithms
that are efficient against an adaptive
adversary
now kaplan monsoon sim and stemmer in
crypto 21 are the first to show a
separation between standard and robust
streaming algorithms
and they show an exponential gap where
the ratio between the space needed for
adaptive and oblivious adversaries is
omega
square root lambda so this shows that
the hasidim and others result is tight
but there's uh
this result is a little
unsatisfactory because
uh the problem that is shown that is
used to show the separation is a highly
artificial problem
so natural follow-up question is
whether we can show a separation for a
natural problem
and as mentioned before the open
question mentioned by stemmer in at a
stop 21 workshop
so
uh for this consider the very simple and
event extraction problem where the input
is a stream of
insertion and relations of l of elements
and whenever queried we want to return
an element with non-zero frequency
uh now before in the obvious adversary
case uh uh using l0 sampling we can
easily solve this using pi log space but
against an adaptive adversary
this problem is omega n space
here's the proof
let's say we have a robust sketch for
element extraction which has processed n
over two elements that are unknown to an
adversary
and let's call this set s we can show
that the adversary can retrieve the
entire set s by just querying the
algorithm
so it acquires the algorithm
uh receives an element let's say one
records it and deletes this element a1
then it queries it again to receive the
next element a2
records it and deletes a2
and so on and so forth until it
retrieves all n over two elements
so it retrieves the intersect s and it
can be shown using basic information
theory that such a sketch
must have
used omega n space
but
there's still a slight quibble about
this uh separation
that is because
uh we showed the separation for a
problem that allows deletions
and we kind of expect that uh problems
on trans style stream are hard against
an active adversary
so we define the question as follows we
want to show a separation
uh for a natural a problem that is on
insert only streams
so now consider the problem of missing
item finding which is kind of a
complement version of element extraction
here we only have string
insertions in the stream
and we when queried we want to return an
element that we have not seen so far
so in the oblivious adversary case using
l0 sampling on the ones complement of
the frequency vector we can again solve
it using polylog space and again against
an adaptive adversary it needs omega in
space the proof is along similar lines
as the last one
uh the
let's say the mif sketch has
processed 10 over two unknown elements
that adversary acquires it receives an
element a1 stores it and inserts this
very element because
it knows it was first missing
it now it queries and gets the new
missing element a2
and it goes so on and so forth until it
receives n over 2 elements and at that
point it knows that it has the
complement of the set s so it knows the
set is exactly
so therefore again by the previous
argument uh
this sketch must have used omega n space
so now we have shown a separation for a
natural problem and on insert only
strings so are we happy now
uh well not quite because this missing
item finding problem although natural
it's not a very well studied and
important problem on its own
so
uh can we define the way further define
the question in this way even can we
show a separation for a problem which is
natural well studied and on insert only
streams and now we answered this in the
affirmative by exhibiting the graph
coloring problem
and the intuition for the separation is
that proper coloring of a graph with a
very small number of colors reveals lots
of missing edges in the graph
and
then
we have this connection to the missing
item finding problem which for which we
know there is a separation
now let me discuss
our
techniques for lower the lower bound
so as a standard for showing streaming
lower bounds we use communication
complexity but we define a new
communication game called subset
avoidance in short avoid with parameters
tab the problem is as follows
so
alice
has an input
subset a of 1 through t and
which has size small a
and she sends a message to bob
who wants to output a
set capital b
of size small b such that it is entirely
disjoint from alice's set a
and now we show that
the length of alice's message that is
the one-way randomized communication
complexity of this problem is omega a
times b over t
using this lemma we shall now
show that robust coloring is hard
let us describe a protocol for
the avoid tab
uh alice receives a
subset a of 1 through n choose 2
and let's say a has size n squared over
8.
now she
takes robust delta plus 1 coloring
algorithm
and defines a graph on n nodes as
follows
so let's say e1 through e and choose 2
are all possible edges or vertex pairs
of the graph
she
picks a
permutation by
uniformly of random using public
randomness that means this permutation
will be also known to bob
and she perfects this permutation of 1
through n and then
adds the edges e i only for those i such
that pi of i is in her set a
we can show that for by this random
permutation of the edges the maximum
degree of the graph which we call delta
naught is roughly n over 4 with high
probability
uh now alice fits this
graph to the algorithm and sends its
state to bob
upon receiving the state bob queries the
algorithm
and receives the delta plus one coloring
algorithm
now what he does is he matches the
nodes pairs of vertices
with
same color
and forms a maximal matching
uh note that
he knows that these edges are missing
from the graph
and therefore the corresponding elements
are missing from alice's set
so he has actually retrieved
n minus at least n minus delta naught
minus one over two known edges because
that is corresponding missing items
analysis set
and this boundary comes from the fact
that each color class has at most one uh
unmatched vertex
and there are delta naught plus one
color classes initially
now whatever does is he adds these edges
to the graph
and queries it again
observe here that both can repeatedly
insert edges to the graph and query it
and expect correct answers because the
algorithm is robust
otherwise he wouldn't be able to
do this again and again now uh the
second thing to observe is that because
of the introduction of the matching the
max degree of the graph
can have increased by at most one
and so now
there are at most delta naught plus two
colors
so
when he adds the matching edges
he retrieves
at least n minus delta naught minus two
over two
uh
known edges
by the previous logic
and then he adds these
edges to the graph and queries it again
and receives the coloring and
continually goes on doing this until the
max degree of the graph it's n minus one
in this case
uh
all vertices can be receive distinct
colors and he won't find missing edges
anymore so it
goes on doing this iteratively and
finally he
gets
one
missing edge
and then the total number of
non edges retrieved is the sum of these
values which we can see is theta of n
minus delta naught whole square and
delta naught was uh proved to be n over
4 roughly so this value is theta of n
squared
now what bob does is he uses
uses popular permutation pi
to
uh
this is a
map to to map these non-non-edges to
missing items analysis set and if
outputs that set b
so the values and verb has solved have a
t a b where t a and b had each uh seen
to be theta n squared
so using this lemma we can see
that the space used by the algorithm is
at least omega a b over t which is omega
n square
and thus we have established this lower
bound
and so this lower bound is for graphs
whose final
max degree is uh delta is like theta n
now for for other graphs with lower max
degree this low lower bound doesn't hold
because even the
graph size is not that much
so for general delta we show that
the lower bound is omega n delta still
linear lower bound and we show this by
reducing from multiple parallel
instances of epoid
now we can further generalize this
result to show that a k coloring
algorithm requires omega n delta squared
over k space
now let me briefly describe our
algorithmic results
so we have two main algorithms a sketch
switching based order delta squared
coloring algorithm in n root delta space
and a fair specification based delta
cube algorithm in same streaming space
let me describe the delta squared coding
algorithm first
so
let's
first i'll describe the sketch switching
framework by ben eliza and others
so let lambda be the flip number that is
number of times the output can change
for a problem and a be a standard
streaming sketch for this problem
now
uh
we initialize lambda many copies of this
standard streaming sketch a a1 through a
lambda and we already maintain a current
sketch which is initialized to a1 so now
when we receive the stream when we get a
query
we check if we need to change and change
our output from the last one by querying
the current sketch
and if we see that we do need to change
the output then we return the output
given by the sketch a1
and
uh move on switch sketch to the next one
and a1 is now
inactive that is it it won't be updated
ever again or used again
so now here the screen proceeds and we
get the next query and we check if we
want to change our need to change our
last output
and if not
then we
repeat that output
so
next let's say we see that we
do need to change our output and then we
use the output from the current sketch
a2 and switch sketch to a3 and a2 will
never be used again
so in this way we go on outputting the
last output as long as
we see that we don't need to change it
and
in this case we don't switch sketches
and otherwise
we
output from the current sketch and
switch to the next one
so this
will give us a robust coloring algorithm
a robust algorithm because
because uh
each uh
whenever we give an output from a sketch
we don't use it anymore and so all
sketches processor streams which are uh
which are independent of its randomness
so all of these sketches will give
correct answer now as you can see that
given an algorithm with space
order s we can get a robust algorithm
with space s times lambda because we
initialize lambda copies of the
algorithm
however for graph coloring the challenge
is that the adversary can force us to
change our output at every point by
introducing an edge between two uh like
colored bones
and then lightly implementing this
framework would uh make us incur an m
factor in space which is no good so we
ask if we can decrease the number of
parallel sketches
and now we describe our algorithm so
let's say we have for some parameter s
to be set later we initialize like s
copies of the
of a standard streaming sketch for for
delta plus one coloring let's say we use
the one by assadigen and khanna
and we also split the stream into s
chunks
and each chunk has size order n delta
over s
because the stream has size order in in
delta
and now how we uh
and what we also do is we buffer a chunk
that is uh we store it entirely and when
we reach its end point we delete it and
move on to to storing the next chunk
now how the algorithm proceeds is that
it
calls the endpoints of the chunkers as
checkpoints and whenever the stream
reaches a checkpoint it uses the current
sketch to obtain a delta plus one
coloring at that point so again the
stream proceeds and it is the second uh
checkpoint
it uses uh the current sketch a2 to get
a coloring and it will never be used
again and so on
now
what do we do when a query arrives well
let's say the stream is coming and then
we receive a query in in the middle of
the stream so we can look at the graph
as a union of g1 and g2 where g1 is the
graph until the last checkpoint and g2
is the current buffer stored
so we just used at the last checkpoint
we last use the sketch to get a color in
chi 1 of g1 and for g2 because we have
it in store we can deterministically
color it and get us coloring kite
so for the
color coloring of the graph g1 union g2
that is the current graph we just take
product of the colorings that is we if
chi 1 assigns color a to a vertex and
chi 2 assigns b then we call it a comma
b
this will be a valid coloring of the
graph and the number of colors used will
be order delta squared
and the space usage is maximum of n
times s because that is the space taken
by
s sketches each of each of uh that you
uh each of which uses n space
and buffering a chunk of takes and delta
over space so now setting s to be square
root delta optimizes the space to be n
root delta
and for uh we can this works for insert
only streams but with a bit more work we
can show that for transfer streams we
have a delta squared algorithm using
space
order square root of nm
and by recursion and substantially more
work we can now generalize it to a delta
for k coloring algorithm using n power 1
minus 1 over k times m power one over k
space
now let me briefly describe the parent
specification based order delta cube
coloring algorithm
so the parent specification framework
introduced by asan and khan and later
studied by alan and nasa these the
following
each vertex samples a list of odd colors
from
a palette of size in a k
and now
what we want is proper coloring such
that every vertex uses a color from its
own list which is called a list coloring
so in this picture we see that this
graph
does admit uh list coloring
and
now uh why it is important for streaming
is that uh if such a lease carding
exists then we only need to store edges
uh whose endpoints have intersecting
lists
for example in for this graph we can get
rid of all these edges
and store a sparse graph
and in general we can show that the
space area that is the number of
conflicting edges
is ordered in delta times r squared over
k
now assadichan and khanna show that such
early scaling exists
for r equals to order log n and k equals
to delta plus one
and this would give you a delta plus one
coloring in what uh same streaming space
however this algorithm is not adversely
robust
now we show
that taking r to be order delta and k to
be ordered delta q we would get a delta
cube algorithm in semi streaming space
plus this algorithm will also be robust
now
the idea behind designing this algorithm
is that each
vertex samples
l lists of colors
and l is an upper bound on the final
value of the max degree delta now each
of these small lists they have size
order login
and how they are sampled is as follows
so we say level i has a disjoint palette
of two i squared colors for i equal to 1
to l
and a color samples its list in level 1
from
the level 1 colors the list in level 2
from level 2 colors and so on
so the total number of colors used at
any point would be summation of 2 i
square psi transform 1 through delta
which is ordered delta q
now how the algorithm proceeds is as
follows when an edge arrives
it
let's call k to be the maximum of of the
degrees of the end points so here that
is one
so it checks if
it's list from level one onwards
intersect
and if they do it stores the
edge
and regardless of whether it's towards
the edge or not it recolors one
arbitrary endpoint using the first
available colored in its list that is
use
the first color that is not taken up by
any of its neighbors and it uses the
color list in level degree of u where u
is the vertex being recolored
now we can see that for the first few
years they will be stored because the
level one list could very likely
intersect
because
they are just drawn from two distinct
colors with replacement
but as the degree gets higher
uh
it becomes more unlikely for the list to
intersect for example here the list from
level two onwards they probably don't
intersect so we don't store this edge
but
we recolor one end point using the first
available color in the in level two
because it's degree is two
and again for this for
edge so let's see that
degree of the vertex is
3
because we
have stored only two edges but
this actual degree in the graph is free
whereas the other endpoints reduce 2 so
we check
lists
from level 3 onwards
and if because if they don't overlap we
don't store this edge but we
recolor one end point
and so this is the algorithm and we can
show its correctness by showing that
with high probability there will always
be an available color for the recoloring
vertex u in level degree of u
and we all can also show that the number
of edges that the adversary can make a
store is no worse than the oblivious
case and for the oblivious case i
already argued in the last slide that
the number of edges is
roughly your tilde n so we get a same
streaming delta q coloring algorithm
there's a caveat that's all these color
lists they would take n delta random
bits
and uh that
if we count it in in our space storage
uh then
that won't give us a sub linear space
algorithm anymore
however uh our ongoing work uh removes
this assumption with uh some fairly new
ideas
so to conclude we showed the first
separation between
standard and robust streaming algorithms
for natural problem and also
between randomized and deterministic
streaming coloring algorithms we
introduced new techniques for showing
robust lower bounds and a new
communication game which might be of
intimate interest
and we also designed a class of
robust carding algorithms which uses
some new techniques
let me end with some open problems the
natural of important question is whether
we can close the gap for some streaming
global scaling algorithms where the
lower bound is omega delta squared and
the upper bound is ordered delta cube uh
we should mention here that our ongoing
work makes some progress uh towards the
upper bound but
we are still working on it
and uh
we also see that our
algorithms for star style streams are
not that efficient if we have very long
streams and so we ask if uh there is
some improvement on that front
and finally the question of uh
whether we can show a separation for a
natural estimation problem is still open
and
suspected candidate is let's say
the second frequency moment on trans
live streams can we completely prove
that separation exists for this problem
for adverse
adaptive and oblivious adversaries
with that i'd like to end thank you for
listening